Das ist wirklich wie aus einem science-fiction-film die esa hat einen neuen revolutionären antrieb für raumfahrzeuge
entwickelt dabei nutzt er die luftmoleküle der oberen atmosphäre vom planeten und ermöglicht so
erheblich längere raummissionen wieder mal einen themenvorschlag der über whatsapp reinkam da seid ihr wirklich absolut hammer
Fantastisch tausend dank wie er da auch mitmachen könnt erfahrt ihr am ende des videos
Also wie der antrieb funktioniert und was das für die raumfahrt. Bedeutet jetzt den klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Es hat kaum jemand mitbekommen aber die esa ist was antriebe für raumfahrzeuge mit dieser
technologie angeht ganz weit vorne sie hat bereits in ihrem coach gravitations satelliten einen elektrischen antrieb
Eingesetzt der satellit hatte die aufgabe anomalien im gravitationsfeld der erde
aufzuspüren denn die erdbeschleunigung von 98 1 meter pro sekunde
Im quadrat ist nicht überall gleich und er suchte zusätzlich nach
energiequellen wärmequellen unter der erdoberfläche die für geothermie genutzt werden können die mission war ein voller erfolg auch dank eines
elektrischen
strahltriebwerke statt wie bei chemischen triebwerken üblich treibstoffe, zu verbrennen
ionisiert dieser antrieb xenon moleküle durch die elektrische ladungen können diese moleküle dann mit elektrischen feldern beschleunigt und
Ausgestoßen werden es entsteht an rückstoß ein bisschen so wie bei der alten fernseher
Röhre hier waren es der elektronen die mithilfe von kathode und anode auf eine bildfläche geschossen wurden bei dem luftschlag
Zwischen antritt sind es moleküle die in den weltraum geschossen werden vorher werden sie noch komprimiert
Um einen deutlich stärkeren rückstoß zu erzeugen doch bisher war für diese technologie immer noch ein
Treibstoff nötig im fall der große mission waren es 40 kilogramm
Xenon die zum einen transportiert werden mussten also gewicht und dann auch noch irgendwann verbraucht?
Waren der satellit stürze zurück auf die erde und verglühte in höhe der falkland inseln vor argentinien
vollständig ende der mission
Doch jetzt hat die esa einen prototypen getestet bei dem das nicht mehr passieren muss kutsche flog nämlich lediglich in einer
höhe von 250 kilometern über der erde eine
Höhe in der der antrieb dazu benutzt wird um vor allem eine gegenkraft gegen den geringen
Luftwiderstand in der dünnen atmosphäre dort zu erzeugen und es gibt zahlreiche
raumfahrzeuge die so tief fliegen um ihre aufgaben erfüllen zu können auch die ssd internationale raumstation
umkreist die erde in einer
Höhe von lediglich 400 kilometern jetzt hat die esa diesen antrieb absolut
revolutionär modifiziert stadt xenon wurde während des testlaufs das edelgas langsam durch
Luftmoleküle ersetzt denn einem solchen antrieb ist es letztlich egal
Mit welchen teilchen er den rückstoß erzeugt zitat als die saison basierte blauer farbe des triebwerk strahlt zu violett
Wechselte wussten wir dass wir es geschafft
hatten das sagt louis wallbott von der esa damit ist tatsächlich eine neue ära der raumfahrt angebrochen denn sie müssen ganz
unterschiedliche raumfahrzeuge kaum noch treibstoff
Mitnehmen ein solcher antrieb würde auch in einen niedrigen mars orbit funktionär würde überall da
Sehr lange missionen ermöglichen wo in irgendeiner weise teilchen angesaugt ionisiert und ausgestoßen werden können in der marsatmosphäre
Könnte das zum beispiel kohlendioxid seien und die elektrische energie die für den antrieb benötigt wird kann einfach durch die sonne mittels solarzellen
erzeugt werden eine unerschöpfliche
energiequelle rosige zeiten brechen also für so manchen missionen an und wir werden dadurch viel besser erkenntnisse erzielen können die saturnsonde cassini
Hätte vielleicht so viel länger, im orbit
des planeten unterwegs sein können und vielleicht sogar durch neue experimente leben auf enceladus
Nachweisen kann wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema raumfahrt und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet hier
meine telefonnummer bei whatsapp
dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert ihr können dort direkt über mich in der redaktion vorliegt so mitmachen und
Mit themen vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen und mitbestimmen was ihr bei pixum passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken hat cassini
außerirdisches leben auf enceladus entdeckt ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran